With some effort, perseverance, and guidance,...
...you'll be able to choose the right career for you.
You will need reflection, research, and a belief in yourself.
Step 1: List your passions and interests.
Do you like working with your hands or sitting at a desk?
Working with numbers or managing money? Teaching or helping people?
Selling or creating things?
Step 2: Identify your strengths, skills, and talents.
Things that come easily that you enjoy doing.
Don't let lack of skills limit your choices.
You can always increase your knowledge and develop new skills.
Step 3: List your personal preferences and needs.
What is the lowest income that you will accept?
Are you willing to commute or relocate?
Can you go back to school for additional training?
Step 4: Get professional advice by taking career assessment tests,...
...and tests that evaluate your personality and temperament.
Some career assessment tests are free. Others are available from a career counselor.
Step 5: Research the job market to learn about careers that match your interests and personality.
Check the US Department of Labor's Occupational Outlook Handbook...
...and Career Guide to Industries found online or at the library.
Step 6: Prepare to begin a new chapter in your life...
...as you pursue a career that will make you happy and bring you satisfaction.
Aim high!
Did you know,...
...Vincent Van Gogh was a school master, a student priest missionary,...
...and an art dealer before he became a painter?